hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season
nine episode 10 titled Omega hopeful has
arrived she looks sick
her daughter Lydia shared her backstory
or backstories get it straight and the
show keeps loving it's confused Henry
reaction shots I'm gonna break all this
down details that you might have missed
in what this all means and how it
connects to the comics and spoiler
warning obviously if you haven't seen
the episode yet and real quick before we
begin thanks to Philo for sponsoring
this video stick around at the end the
video to learn how you can start
watching episodes of The Walking Dead
within seconds with just a phone number
no credit card needed to start a free
trial okay this episode is titled omega
the Whisperer name given to Lydia
daughter of alpha alpha is the first
letter of the Greek alphabet Omega is
last and these terms are how we describe
the hierarchy within packs of animals
like wolves the Alpha is the strongest
the fiercest the leader of the group the
Omega is the runt the weakest the one
that they all beat up on by the way
after episodes titled evolution and
adaptation this makes a turkey of
episode titles lifted from biology
textbooks the whisperers have adopted an
animalistic pack hierarchy in order to
survive in this episode we learn about
the foundations of this ideology through
the eyes of the runt the Omega even if
she's really not that much of a true
Omega but I'll get into that more later
it opens with an early outbreak
flashback to a younger Lydia her father
Frank and her mother who you'll notice
never gets named that anonymity is key
because as far as we know this woman is
only alpha and even the story presented
to us through Lydia's eyes can't really
be trusted because as we learn later
Lydia is an unreliable narrator the
unreliable narrator is a storytelling
device and which scenes are depicted
that didn't actually happen or they have
inconsistent details that don't make
sense because it's all being presented
from a biased source a character who's
lying or someone who's suffering from a
mental illness each time we revisit
Lydia's backstory her memory changes
slightly it all begins 23 days into the
outbreak in the Baltimore area with her
mother as a nurturing protective figure
who tattooed Lydia's name on her arm and
lets her trace it to calm down while she
sings this lullaby of Lydia the tattooed
lady which is an old Groucho Marx song
Lydia Lydia that lady this could also be
a nod to Breaking Bad and the final
episode of that series Todd cellphone
had a custom ringtone for when Lydia
called The Walking Dead as reference
Breaking Bad a few times before
remember Merle's bag of drugs included
some crystal blue meth in these earlier
scenes Frank the father is initially
depicted as a strict heartless figure
the scary beard scary because it's never
the same in one memory we see him
trimming it and then another he's
clean-shaven and then suddenly he is a
nurturing figure with the Lydia tattoo
in the lullaby and then later the mother
switches characters and she appears with
shorter scissor cut hair also notice the
memory of Lydia and her mom playing
checkers the mom says checkmate as a
joke and then jumps back into the
present with Lydia remembering it as he
always said that before suddenly cutting
herself off and changing it to she all
the memories that Lydia has her mother
is a sweet kind figure or actually
memories of her father which her mother
brainwashed out of her memory through
years of abuse Frank never cut his beard
it was Lydia's mother cutting her hair
Lydia's mother is played by character
actors Samantha Morton whom you might
know is the precognitive Agatha and
Minority Report I like how this shift in
detail of which parent was using the
scissors in the past echoes the scissors
imagery and Agatha's similarly murky
future vision in the opening sequence of
Minority Report with the scissors as a
tool of the murderer Henry and Lydia
compared her mother to Carol and it's
interesting to look at these two as
parallel figures to widows who have worn
masks arguably the deadliest wolves of
their respective packs actually if you
remember during that whole wolf attack a
couple seasons back Carol similarly
blend it in and went on a deadly
Massacre just like alpha wood and Henry
reminds us this episode how Carroll once
also cut her hair short created herself
from domesticity but really trying to
free yourself from her abusive husband
Edie
so that he wouldn't have something to
grab an abuser the Walking Dead has also
introduced newcomers in the past with
early outbreak flashbacks remember Enid
was introduced in a similar way actually
Lydia tells Henry that the world now
belongs to the dead and they're just
living in it which is a callback to a
similar line that Enid said to Carlin
season 5
when he was trying to bring her into the
civilized world really Lydia and Henry's
relationship is mapped more closely on
Karl in Lydia in the comics issues 136
137 138 which scarred us all with the
panel of Lydia licking Carl's I Hall wha
thankfully for us henry has both his
eyes so instead the episode gives us
this gross out moment of Lydia eating
the worm and making him eat one too okay
speaking of comic adaptations kudos to
Samantha Morton in the crew for the look
of alpha compared to the relatively
clean look of alpha in the comics this
one is the gross garbage person that
someone who wore rotting human flesh on
their face all the time would actually
look like an episode filled with so many
visual inconsistencies the one that
interests me the most has to do with
Darryl
check out his vest maybe I'm only just
seeing this now but notice how one of
the angel wings on the back has been
torn off last time I remember seeing it
when the bridge exploded right before
the time jump he definitely had both
wings so what happened to the other one
I think there's a good chance it's
connected to the X scars on his and
Michonne's backs but Sean might also
have a piece of herself that was cut off
sometime during a time jump some of her
dreads definitely appear to have been
buzzed away Darryl has a second X car up
in his right shoulder exactly where the
wing patch used to be on his vest so
what else did these two have to give up
in addition to fashion items and maybe
kidneys if this effed up mystery event
was connected to where Rick went maybe
they could have severed these parts as a
way to say goodbye to Rick let's get
back to this idea of Omega a word that's
never spoke in this episode only alluded
to with the reveal of the name alpha and
this mother's abuse of Lydia Darryl
realizes that Lydia's memories of her
parents are inconsistent and that her
mother must have been the one to give
her the bruises on her arm presumably
these beatings are what make Lydia the
Omega of their pack in the comics it's
actually way darker alpha lets the
whisperer men rape Lydia with the belief
that things like rape and consent don't
exist in the animal kingdom and the
weakest deserve to be dominated we'll
see if the show goes this far I doubt it
will but either way I don't know if
Lydia deserves the Omega label this
episode but she spends most of it
lecturing Henry about how they're too
weak and how their communities will
eventually fall she even nearly Club
to death with a hammer if not for a past
trauma triggering an attack he'd be gone
really I think the true Omega of this
episode isn't Lydia at all it's Henry
look when you're at the bottom feeder
Omega of a pack you're desperate to
climb up even a little bit and I think
millennia definitely slipped on top of
Henry this episode phrasing I know I
know there are bars between them this
episode was the story of the Omega of
one pack testing the Omega of a rival
pack and realizing that she's way
tougher indicating to her and to anyone
measuring packs by their weakest links
that this new pack is far more savage
than they are which character do you
think is the weakest link the Omega on
The Walking Dead comment down below with
your thoughts and thanks again to Philo
who sponsored this video and really made
our return weekly coverage of The
Walking Dead possible Philo is a
streaming service with over 50 channels
including things like AMC Comedy Central
it's really the easiest way to watch The
Walking Dead you can start watching
within seconds all you need is a phone
number no credit card is required you
can start a free trial there's unlimited
recording so you can save as many shows
as you want
Philo's available on Apple TV Roku
Android iOS Fire TV it's simple it's
affordable only $20 a month for all of
this content you can essentially save
100 bucks a month on your cable bill
Philo is your best solution to stay cord
free and commitment free just visit WWF
Aiello TV slash new rock stars
that's pH ILO dot TV slash new rockstars
follow me on twitter and instagram at a
vas it subscribed the new rock stars and
subscribe to our podcast where we listen
to podcasts thanks for watching and
thanks to the walking dead for reminding
us of edy a good wait for Jon Bernthal
the releases rage of her Netflix
canceling the punisher bring castles
stop it's already dead
[Music]